can you get suspended from school for
making memes I student in Tennessee was
suspended for three days after posting
memes of his principal to Instagram in
one meme the principal is an anime cat
and another he's being hugged by a
cartoon bird and in another the student
wrote my brother over the principal
holding a box of produce
the three-day suspension is the same
punishment kids get for fist fighting in
this school but administrators said the
meme's violated school policy against
posting photos that embarrassed to mean
or discredit any student or staff member
respectfully This is BS the Supreme
Court decided two years ago that public
schools can't punish students for
off-campus speech that isn't
substantially disruptive students have a
First Amendment right to mock school
officials on social media as long as it
doesn't cause a substantial disruption
on campus the memes in this case didn't
cause A disruption at school but they
did disrupt the principles you go